[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
mietri Serien hallo und einen schönen
guten Abend christine hat später Fußball
und Radsport im Angebot viel los bei uns
guten Abend dann blicken wir jetzt
gemeinsam auf die Themen an diesem
Mittwoch
das e-rezept wird Pflicht ab Januar 2024
gibt es für die meisten Versicherten
Medikamente nur noch mit digitaler
Verschreibung
kein Ende in Sicht in Portugal stehen
immer noch große Gebiete in Flammen
und Gastronomie schlägt Alarm nach dem
Ende der Pandemie soll die
Mehrwertsteuer auf Speisen wieder
steigen
[Musik]
arztrezepte in Papierform wird für
gesetzlich Versicherte bald nicht mehr
geben sie werden ersetzt durch ihre
Rezepte die meisten Apotheken die machen
bei der digitalen Variante seit gut 4
Wochen mit in vielen Arztpraxen hapert
es aber bei der Umsetzung und auch darum
sprachgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
heute davon dass Deutschland bei der
Digitalisierung Entwicklungsland sei und
macht jetzt Druck ab kommendem Jahr sind
Ärzte verpflichtet e-rezepte
auszustellen Patienten müssen dann nicht
mehr zwingend in die Praxis kommen die
e-rezepte werden auf einem zentralen
Server gespeichert und können in
Apotheken über die Gesundheitskarte
abgerufen werden mehr von Heike landski
Arztbesuch mit Minister das kommt nicht
häufig vor Karl Lauterbach will für das
eRezept werben das in dieser
ausgewählten Praxis bereits zum Alltag
gehört vorausgesetzt eine elektronische
Gesundheitskarte ein Lesegerät und die
entsprechende Software ich signiers das
rosafarbene Rezept soll bald der
Geschichte angehören längst überfällig
modern zeitsparend so der Minister wir
sind im Bereich der Digitalisierung
unseres Gesundheitssystems ein
Entwicklungsland das ist leider so wir
brauchen daher eine Aufholjagd diese
Aufholjagd beginnt mit dem
elektronischen Rezept nach Jahren des
Stillstands macht der Minister nun Druck
das Ehre Rezept ab Januar verpflichtend
folgen soll die elektronische
Patientenakte die Ärzteschaft teils
kritisch
es birgt sicherlich enorme Vorteile für
die pharmazeutische Industrie für die
Krankenkassen für die Ärzte ist es im
Moment einfach nur mehr Aufwand das hat
mit Transparenz nichts zu tun sondern
mit einer dysfunktionalen digitalen
Landschaft die wir in Deutschland haben
der Gang in die Apotheke ohne
Zettelwirtschaft ohne Smartphone mehr
als 80 Prozent erfüllen lautverband die
Voraussetzungen seit Anfang Juli sein
2,4 Millionen Rezepte digital eingelöst
worden mit dem eRezept sind Fehler in
der Medikation falsches Medikament oder
Medikamente die sich nicht miteinander
vertragen oder Medikamente die
umgestellt werden müssen in der
Dosierung zum Beispiel all diese Fehler
die passieren können sind damit viel
unwahrscheinlicher Deutschland und die
Digitalisierung alle Datenschutzbedenken
erfüllt und trotzdem noch ein weiter Weg
wie das e-rezept für sie in der Praxis
funktioniert dazu haben wir viele Infos
in unserer ZDF heute-
der nationale CO2-Preis den Verbraucher
für Heizen mit Gas und Öl und beim
Tanken zahlen soll steigen die
Bundesregierung plant nach
Medienberichten des eine Tonne
Kohlendioxid ab Januar statt bisher 30
dann 40 Euro kostet dadurch werden laut
Experten Berechnungen Benzin und Diesel
um etwa 4 Cent pro Liter teurer die
Einnahmen sollen in den Klima und
transformations-
lange hat China die Weltwirtschaft ja
angekurbelt steckt jetzt aber seit
Monaten in der Krise auch heute kamen
alarmierende Wirtschaftsdaten aus Peking
die Chinesen konsumieren immer weniger
und das ist schlecht für Industrie und
Konjunktur für Deutschland ist China ja
einer der wichtigsten Handelspartner aus
keinem anderen Land kommen so viele
Güter zu uns Tendenz steigen zuletzt
12,8%
. und anders ist der Trend bei den
Ausfuhren da ist China vom
zweitwichtigsten Exportland auf Rang 4
abgerutscht aus Peking berichtet jetzt
für uns Miriam steineimer
Schlange stehen vor dem Tempel so
sieht's am Lama Tempel in Peking schon
seit vielen Wochen aus es sind vor allem
junge Menschen sie kommen mit ihren
Wünschen und hoffen dass eine höhere
Macht sie erfüllt
wir beten dass wir gute Praktikumsplätze
bekommen und gute Jobmöglichkeiten haben
werden
ich hoffe dass ich einen Job finde ich
suche schon seit einer Weile die
Jobsituation ist echt angespannt
es sind Chinas Wirtschaftszahlen die
immer mehr junge Leute zum Tempel locken
jeder fünfte unter 25 ist arbeitslos ein
Rekord hoch
die Reihe der schlechten
Wirtschaftszahlen geht heute weiter das
Statistikbüro verkündet dass die
Verbraucherpreise im Juli im Vergleich
zum Vorjahr um 0,3% fehlen zum ersten
Mal seit mehr als zwei Jahren was nach
einer guten Nachricht klingt zeigt wie
schlecht die Stimmung im Land ist denn
die Menschen zögern Geld auszugeben zum
Beispiel für Immobilien
das Problem auf dem chinesischen
Immobilienmarkt ist die sinkende
Nachfrage
es werden weniger Wohnungen verkauft die
Preise fallen und das das so enorme
Auswirkungen hat hat einfach damit zu
tun wie groß der Immobiliensektor ist
von seiner Rolle für Chinas Wirtschaft
nämlich 30 Prozent des chinesischen
Bruttoinlandsprodukts in den Städten
sieht das so aus Millionen leerstehende
und halbfertige bauten die
Immobilienkrise stoppte die Bauarbeiten
auf Entschädigungen warten die meisten
noch heute
gleichzeitig ist es auch so dass im
Privatsektor wo vier Fünftel der
chinesischen Arbeitskräfte beschäftigt
sind ein Drittel der Unternehmen Ende
Mai Verluste eingefahren haben das ist
die höchste Zahl seit 2001 laut Umfragen
kommen 5 Mal so viele Menschen zum
Tempel wie im Vorjahr chinesische
Reiseanbieter betrachten diese Jugend
inzwischen als wichtige Zielgruppe und
organisieren tempelreisen
es ist ein schwerwiegender Verdacht die
Bundesanwaltschaft wirft einem
Mitarbeiter des Bundesamtes für
Ausrüstung und Informationstechnik der
Bundeswehr Spionage für Russland vor
heute wurde gegen den deutschen
Staatsangehörigen Haftbefehl erlassen ab
Mai soll er der russischen Botschaft
mehrfach eine Zusammenarbeit angeboten
haben
Deutschland unterstützt die Ukraine mit
einer weiteren Lieferung von
Kampfpanzern der Rüstungskonzerne
Rheinmetall hat dafür rund 50 alte
ausgemusterte Leopard Panzer aus Belgien
gekauft einige sind allerdings in so
schlechtem Zustand dass sie
ausgeschlachtet werden um andere
Fahrzeuge einsatzfähig zu machen die
Zahl lieferfähiger Panzer beläuft sich
dann auf rund 30 sie sollen dann im
Auftrag der Bundesregierung in die
Ukraine geschickt werden
Waldbrände haben Südeuropa vor rund drei
Wochen in Atem gehalten inzwischen hat
sich die Lage fast überall entspannt
außer in Portugal dort bleibt es weiter
extrem heiß trocken und windig die Folge
ständig breiten sich neue Feuer aus
zuletzt sowohl im Norden im Zentrum des
Landes und auch im Süden aber selten
enden die Brände tragisch weil Portugal
schnell reagiert und evakuiert auch
jetzt bei Sau Miguel und von dort Thomas
Walde
es ist der bislang größte Brand in
diesem Sommer an der Algarve 10.000
Hektar Wald sind in Flammen aufgegangen
1.000 Feuerwehrleute sind im Einsatz
die Arbeit der Feuerwehrleute und des
Zivilschutzes die ganze Nacht hindurch
hat zu einer gewissen Stabilisierung der
Lage geführt
nachdem im Jahr 2017 mehr als 100
Menschen bei brennenden umkamen
evakuieren die Behörden frühzeitiger so
auch in Zombie gell
der Feuerwehrmann kam rein und hat nur
gerufen raus jetzt sofort raus
behördlich angeordnete Evakuierungen
sind für Anwohner verpflichtend wer
nicht folgt riskiert eine Anzeige
wir mussten in unserem Kreis keine Leute
zu Evakuierung zwingen aber wir hätten
das als letzte Maßnahme getan wenn sie
nicht mitgegangen wären weil Sie nicht
nur sich sondern auch die Rettungskräfte
in Gefahr bringen würden
mit ihrer Strategie begrenzen die
Behörden die Folgen der Brände für
Menschen es gibt bislang zwei Dutzend
leicht verletzte vor allem durch Rauch
nach den schweren und großflächigen
Überschwemmungen verspricht die EU
Slowenien schnelle Hilfen in Höhe von
bis zu 400 Millionen Euro
kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
machte sich vor Ort ein Bild von den
Zerstörungen im Dorf tscherna
nakoreschkem nahe der Grenze zu
Österreich zeigte sie sich beeindruckt
von der Tatkraft und dem Optimismus der
Menschen
anhaltende schwere regenfäller hatten in
Slowenien enorme Schäden angerichtet es
gab mindestens sechs Tote
Starkregen und Überschwemmungen haben
auch im Baltikum und Skandinavien
schwere Schäden angerichtet im Süden
Norwegen die Fluten Hütten und Wohnwagen
mit die Einsatzkräfte mussten hunderte
Menschen in Sicherheit bringen
dramatisch ist auch die Lage an einem
Wasserkraftwerk dort stauten sich die
Wassermassen so sehr dass Teile des
Dammes brachen
wie schnell ein Brand tödlich enden kann
hat sich auf dramatische Weise heute im
Elsass gezeigt 11 Menschen kamen ums
Leben Ortes Unglücks ist vinzenheim nahe
Kollmar früher am Morgen war der Brand
dort in einem Ferienheim ausgebrochen
die Opfer gehört zu einer Reisegruppe
von Menschen mit geistiger
Beeinträchtigung eine Art
bin in weniger Minuten bricht das Dach
unter den Flammen zusammen brennt das
Ferienhaus früh morgens im Elsass 17
Personen können sich ins Freie retten
elf Gäste die in der oberen Etage
schlafen sterben
die Personen im Obergeschoss hatten
offenbar Schwierigkeiten rauszukommen
denn dort haben wir die leichten
gefunden aber wir wissen nicht genau
warum sie von den Flammen eingeschlossen
wurden
die Analyse steht noch am Anfang die
Ruine sowie das Gelände werden
untersucht von einem mutmaßlichen
schwedebrand ist zunächst die Rede 28
Erwachsene damit mehr als von der Gruppe
angemeldet sollen sich in dem
Fachwerkhaus aufgehalten haben auch die
Vermieterin wird befragt für große
bekannt ist dass das Gebäude vor drei
Jahren renoviert wurde und dass alle
Regeln eingehalten wurden jetzt müssen
die Ermittlungen zeigen warum 11
Personen ihr Leben bei diesem Brand
verloren haben
die Betroffenheit ist groß hier so wie
im ganzen Land Frankreichs
Premierministerin besucht den Brandort
natürlich werden wir sicherstellen dass
alle Opfer und ihre Angehörigen nun gut
betreut werden
eine spontane Trauerzeremonie die in
diesen Minuten beginnt soll ersten
nach einem Bootsunglück mit Flüchtlingen
im Mittelmeer werden nach Angaben der
Vereinten Nationen mindestens 40
Menschen vermisst das Boot war schon in
der Nacht zu Freitag vor der
italienischen Insel Lampedusa gecannt
hat das berichten Überlebende das
italienische Innenministerium zählte in
diesem Jahr mehr als 93.000 Menschen die
auf Booten Italien erreichten im
Vorjahreszeitraum waren es nur knapp
halb so viele
viele Flüchtlinge kommen auch aus
Afghanistan nach dem chaotischen Abzug
der NATO übernahmen die islamistischen
Taliban dort wieder die Herrschaft seit
zwei Jahren ist die wirtschaftliche
Situation verheerend immer mehr
Hilfsorganisationen ziehen sich zurück
und wohl in keinem Land der Welt haben
sich die rechte junger Mädchen und
Frauen dermaßen verschlechtert
Afghanistan ist isoliert für uns dort
war Katrin Eigendorf
die Schulen sind Ihnen ab der sechsten
Klasse verschlossen sie müssen sich
einer strengen Kleiderordnung
unterwerfen sind der Willkür der Männer
ausgesetzt
Berufstätigkeit ist ihnen bis auf wenige
Ausnahmen verwehrt Frauen in Afghanistan
sind die großen Verliererinnen nach der
Machtübernahme der Taliban haben sie
fast all ihre mühsamen errungenen Rechte
und Freiheiten verloren jedoch kann wer
sich geschickt verhält vielleicht einen
kleinen Freiraum aushandeln
tabasum war früher Journalistin jetzt
verkauft sie Kleidung in einem
Wäschegeschäft in Kabul soll ihnen denn
ein Mann Frauenkleidung verkaufen mit
diesem Argument hat sie eine
Sondererlaubnis der Sitten strengen
Taliban erwirkt ich fühle mich wie ein
Vogel der mal frei war und nun in einem
Käfig gefangen ist ja wir leben aber wir
haben keine Freude am Leben
geduldet wird Frauen arbeiten noch im
Krankenhaus wo die erste Generation der
Taliban Herrschaft ums Überleben kämpft
es sind vor allem Mangelkrankheiten die
diese Kinder quälen
wir behalten nur die hier die keine
Verbesserungen zeigen das sind schon 700
bis 1000 wenn wir zehn entlassen stehen
schon wieder 20 vor der Tür
die einzige Hilfe kommt aus Deutschland
eine Ärzteorganisation aus dem Sauerland
schickt Medikamente sonst gäbe es für
diese Kinder gar keine Hoffnung mehr
die Doku inside Afghanistan Alltag unter
den Taliban können Sie um 20 nach zehn
sehen oder jederzeit bei uns in der
Mediathek
beim amazonasgipfel im brasilianischen
haben sich die acht Anrainerstaaten auf
eine gemeinsame Erklärung geeinigt die
Länder wollen beim Umweltschutz enger
zusammenarbeiten sie konnten sich aber
nicht darauf einigen die Regenwald
Abholzung zu stoppen und Ölförderung im
Amazonasgebiet zu verbieten klimaschutz-
alarmierende Zahlen kommen von der
kaufmännischen Krankenkasse die
psychischen Belastungen Berufstätiger
Menschen haben nach einer Untersuchung
der KKH massiv zugenommen die Fehlzeiten
wegen seelischer Leiden sind danach im
Vergleich zum ersten Halbjahr 22 um 85%
gestiegen besonders betroffen Menschen
die in sozialen Berufen arbeiten der
Altenpflege und der Kinderbetreuung
ja wieder hoch auf 19% statt 7 wie
zurzeit die Mehrwertsteuer auf Speisen
in Restaurants soll Anfang nächsten
Jahres wieder steigen die Branche warnt
tausende Betriebe sein gefährdet in der
corona-zeit war die Mehrwertsteuer
gesenkt worden um die Gastronomie zu
entlasten wegen hoher Energiepreise war
die Regelung verlängert worden antoniani
berichtet
es läuft im Stuttgarter
Traditionsgasthaus alte Kanzlei die
corona-krise hat der Betrieb gut
überstanden doch wie viele Kollegen
steht wird Dennis schipple immer wieder
von neuen Herausforderungen der
Kostendruck in der Gastronomie ist enorm
ob das Personal ist ob das Energie ist
ob das sonstige Kostenpunkte sind das
ist irre mittlerweile die Senkung des
Mehrwertsteuersatzes für Speisen von 19
auf 7% in 2020 hat die Gastro-Branche
deutlich entlastet zum Jahresende läuft
die Frist für die Steuererleichterung
aus dann wären wieder 19% fällig das
würde für uns bedeuten eine sofortige
Erhöhung der Verkaufspreise am
Endverbraucher die Werte fürchten dann
drastischen Umsatzrückgang der
Branchenverband DEHOGA warnt vor
tausenden Betriebsschließungen und
appelliert an die Politik
wir wollen das Gastronomie bezahlbar ist
dass jeder Mensch sich das auch künftig
weiterhin leisten kann und ich glaube
das ist für die Gesellschaft für die
Innenstädte und auch für das Miteinander
in unserem Land von ganz zentraler
Bedeutung die Probleme der Branche sind
vielfältig und oft auch hausgemacht die
Bundesregierung hat sich in Sachen
Mehrwertsteuer noch nicht festgelegt
experten sehen vor allem den Zeitpunkt
kritisch für die Rücknahme einer
Steuervergünstigung ist es wichtig den
richtigen Zeitpunkt zu finden und dieser
Zeitpunkt ist sicherlich nicht in einer
Wirtschaftskrise in einer
wirtschaftsflotte wo die Betriebe
bereits unter Druck sind die
Gastro-Branche hat in zwei Jahren schon
mehr als 30.000 Betriebe verloren die
Mehrwertsteuererhöhung könnte viele
weitere in Not bringen
Ruhetag bei der Frauenfußball WM
Christine dann schauen wir mal zu den
Männern und da geht's jetzt bald wieder
zum DFB-Pokal bald heißt Freitag Abend
geht's los und zu Beginn spielt auch der
Verein der nach dem FC Bayern München
mit 12 teilnahmen bisher am
zweithäufigsten im Pokalfinale stand
Schalke 04 die Königsblauen müssen zum
zweitliga-duell zu Eintracht
Braunschweig
Gefühlsschwankungen auf Schalke den
Forst über die Auftrag Niederlage in
Hamburg folgte die Freude über den Sieg
gegen Kaiserslautern am letzten Samstag
zuverlässigster Torschütze bisher Simon
Terodde rekordtorjäger der zweiten
Bundesliga er genießt die Abwechslung
vom Liga-Alltag
jetzt kommt man nach Wettbewerb da
freuen wir uns richtig drauf weil es ein
geiler Wettbewerb ist und ja da können
wir die Liga mal ein bisschen
ausklammern und ja dann dann werden wir
sicherlich um halb elf circa die zweite
Runde feiern
[Applaus]
beim letzten t
itel genau
im Team glorreiche Zeiten 12 Jahre
später haben die Westfalen längst nicht
mehr diese finanziellen Voraussetzungen
[Applaus]
allerdings Braunschweig gegen Schalke
Freitagabend live im ZDF dazu weitere
Höhepunkte des Pokal Auftakts ja erneut
ein erfolgreicher Tag für die deutschen
bei den radweltmeisterschaften in
Glasgow in der paradisziplin Dreirad
gewinnt Maximilian Jäger bei den Männern
Gold und seine Teamkollegin Angelika
drewok Käse gewinnt Silber und bereits
ihre zweite Medaille bei diesen Titel
kämpfen in Schottland verbucht Meike
Hausberger nach Bronze im Zeitfahren
sogar überraschend Gold im quetsch
so recht glauben können sie es alle
nicht im deutschen Team Maike Hausberger
als Außenseiterin gestartet als sie
gewinnen im Ziel ein Traum wird wahr
das ja zu gewinnen war eine Überraschung
und ja es ist total schön 17
Starterinnen 40 Runden dass die Zahlen
zu diesem scratch WM-Finale bei dem sich
Maike Hausberger auf den letzten Metern
im Schlusssprint durchsetzt dieser sieht
nur wenige Stunden davor noch
unvorstellbar
[Applaus]
gut dass sie aufgestanden ist wäre doch
echt schade um diese schöne Goldmedaille
echt eine herrliche Geschichte oder
danke schön so Mittwoch ist ja Lotto Tag
und vor bevor wir zu den Zahlen bei uns
kommen werden wir mal einen Blick auf
diese unscheinbare Lottoannahmestelle in
Jacksonville Florida Essen und Apotheke
steht da vorne drauf Essen Apotheke und
Milliarden könnte es vielleicht bald
heißen denn ein Glückspilz hat hier zwei
Dollar investiert und die Rekordsumme
von sage und schreibe umgerechnet
1,44 Milliarden Euro gewonnen
so das passt dann sind wir jetzt bei
unseren Lottozahlen und die gehen so
16 24 29 33 35 37 und die Superzahl 7
weitere Gewinnzahlen und Infos auf
lotto.zdf.de und auf der ZDF Text Seite
der wirklich echte Hochsommer kommt
zurück es wird deutlich wärmer und
sonniger mehr gleich von Katja horneffer
das heute journal gibt es um 21 Uhr 50
mit Maria das lomka das war es von uns
schönen Dank und noch ein entspannten
Abend für Sie
[Musik]
guten Abend jetzt kommt Lotte das Hoch
Lotte vertreibt die letzten Regenwolken
hier nach Osten und bevor das nächste
Tief Arendt übernimmt wird es bei uns
erstmal sonnig und warm der gewittrige
Regen in Bayern lässt schon heute Nacht
mehr und mehr nach es gibt vielleicht
noch letzte Regenschauer an der Ostsee
sonst ist es aber auch mal klar und dann
bildet sich Nebel die Temperaturen
sinken auf 15 Grad an der Nordsee und
bis 7 Grad zum Beispiel im Sauerland und
morgen erwarten uns meistwerte von 20
bis 28 Grad und am wärmsten wird's mal
wieder am Oberrhein etwas kühler ist es
nur an den Küsten von
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und
Schleswig-Holstein mit 18 Grad das wird
ein sehr sonniger Tag nur über
Norddeutschland ziehen einige
Wolkenfelder hinweg und dann kann an der
Ostsee ein kleiner Regenschauer nicht
völlig ausgeschlossen werden vielleicht
regnet es auch noch mal ganz leicht hier
in Niederbayern bei Westwind der Freitag
bringt dann noch mehr Sonnenschein bei
höheren Temperaturen 20 bis 30 Grad
werden das dann das Wochenende wird dann
allerdings zum Teil wieder warm und
gewittrig am Samstag gibt's Schauer
Gewitter vor allen Dingen im Westen am
Sonntag im Südosten guten Abend